ils en ont ras le bol
mais
et c'est à ottawa ils ont choisi de
déverser toute leur frustration
madame leuthard
je tapote mes amants sont à bones ont
emmené autodétruit françois bissonnette
travail comme opérateur de pelle dans le
secteur de la construction il est parti
à 6h ce matin de mirabel jeu pendant
l'année je travaille en jetons et
d'allumer le sachet qui réclament la
liberté commence l'ex pas eu les doigts
de vaccin et non dans le trou tenez
oui si les manifestants affluent vers
ottawa ils en ont aussi contre le
gouvernement legault et ses mesures
sanitaires
le gouvernement trudeau que vous
manifestez qui manifestent par contre
quelque chose je manifeste pour quelque
chose c'est différent cette grand mère
qui habite en outaouais ne veut pas nous
donner son nom il entend revenir au
centre-ville toute la semaine s'il le
faut on est ici pour apprendre aux
libertés par arrêté pour ta mère comme
vous en affaires soient liées à
l'école à s'armer
et des enfants il y en a dans la foule
comme tyler et son petit frère de 6 ans
ou est ce les sont venus de sarnia en
ontario ils ont préparé des dessins pour
les camionneurs
les coups de klaxon fort tellement
assourdissant qu'on a du mal à leur
parler
[Musique]
en début d'après-midi la foule se
densifie
on peine à se faufiler entre les
milliers de manifestants non masqué
et policiers d'autres villes ont même
été appelés en renfort
malgré tout farès venus de montréal dans
sa belle voiture ne s'inquiète pas pour
sa sécurité sinon on est civilisés en
veste et civilisée mais on veut se
montrer qu'elle ment on n'est pas une
minorité un peu plus au juste à côté du
parlement bien des protestataires ont
trouvé celui qui porte leur voix
politiques
malgré le froid malgré la température je
sais pour dire aux gens qui siègent
derrière nous assez c'est assez on veut
retrouver notre liberté
à la nuit tombée une partie des
manifestants se dispersent mais
centre-ville d'ottawa reste toujours
complètement immobilisés dans l'eau
chaude ben on ne distingue en voiture
vous si vous mangez
[Musique]
ceux qui restent sont bien décidés à
faire la pac
[Musique]
steven comme tant d'autres ne sait pas
quand il retournera chez lui ni quel
impact il aura mais au moins croit-il
leur a été entendu si le rapportait
radio canada ottawa